this is the moment a huge fire came
rolling down the foothills of boulder
county in colorado
the fast moving blaze engulfed hundreds
of homes
locals say they haven't experienced
anything like it
you know this is the first time i've
really been involved in anything like
this and i'll tell you it is really
scary the ditches and things and the
trees oh they're all up in flames like
there's embers everywhere so it makes me
very frightened of course with the wind
that it's going to
continue to spread to other homes
strong winds and dry conditions are
fueling the flames
officials say some of the fires were
sparked by falling power lines which
ignited prairie grasses
a state of emergency has been declared
and tens of thousands of people
evacuated from the towns of superior and
louisville
many are getting stuck in traffic jams
as they tried to escape
gusts of 110 miles an hour
can and have moved this fire
down a football field in a matter of
seconds
very little time to get out
very little time to even get the most
important parts of your life we
currently have thousands of individuals
in the south south part of our county
and in the areas of superior and
lewisville who have been evacuated
we know that there are structures both
homes and businesses that have been
burned and lost i'm speaking about
hundreds of structures
in boulder county tens of thousands of
people have been left in the dark with
power lines down or destroyed
patients in critical care are being
moved out of hospitals because of the
threat from smoke
winds are gradually weakening giving
firefighters some respite but the
billowing smoke could be a bigger hazard
as it travels across colorado
laura about manly al jazeera